there are thousands of applications that
you can run on google cloud compute
engine each with different requirements
to meet those requirements google cloud
offers vm families each optimized for
specific needs
i'm going to help you make sense of it
by reviewing some important factors to
consider when choosing the right compute
engine vm
if you want to choose the right vm first
let's review how vms are organized in
google cloud
all vms are categorized into either
general purpose or workload optimized
families
general purpose machines provide the
best price performance ratio for a
variety of workloads
as of right now there are three machine
types within the general purpose family
efficient machines deliver reliable
sustained performance the lowest total
cost ownership of any vm and google
cloud
they're about 31 percent cheaper than n1
machines
balance machines offer more
customization and a wider feature set
and tau which represents torque and
physics puts the pedal to the metal for
industry-leading price performance
tau is recommended for scale out
workloads such as web servers
containerized microservices and media
transcoding
is our first offering in the tao family
and provides full x86 compatibility on
third gen amd epic processors
as you go through the three types of
general purpose machines efficient
bounce and tau
they each have different levels of price
performance
where efficient achieves the best price
balance sits in between providing the
most feature flexibility and tau has the
best price performance ratio as for
those workload optimized machines there
are three families here too compute
optimized machines will offer the
highest consistent performance per core
ideal for users with performance
intensive workloads
c2 vms are built on architecture that
utilizes features like non-uniform
memory access to achieve the highest
performance
memory optimized machines are best
suited for memory intensive application
providing the largest ratio of compute
to memory and the lowest cost per
gigabyte of memory they provide the
largest sap certified machines with up
to 12 terabytes of storage and
accelerator optimized machines they
offer the highest gpu performance for
those heavy artificial intelligence
machine learning workloads
google cloud is the first platform to be
able to attach 16 a100 gpus to a single
vm allowing you mega performance to
scale up and out
okay that's how they're organized but
that won't help you choose between a
general purpose n2d high cpu 64 and a
memory optimized m1 mega mem96 for
instance
these names don't exactly roll off the
tongue but understanding the naming
convention going on here is a viable
step towards making the right choice
it's pretty simple the first part of the
name refers to the machine series
this will tell you the category of the
machine for example n2 machines run
intel and n2d denotes amd and both are
categorized as general purpose
each series is available as different
machine types that's there in the middle
each type has a different virtual cpu to
memory ratio to fit different workload
requirements
like high mem high cpu standard etc
lastly the name ends the number which
refers to the number of virtual cpus for
that machine
so now you can deduce that an n2d high
cpu 64 has 64 virtual cpus and as part
of the high cpu type it has one virtual
cpu to one gigabyte of memory ratio in
the n2d series which is in the general
purpose family
in contrast the m1 mega man 96 has 96
virtual cpus and we know it'll have a
higher ratio of memory because it's in
the memory optimized family of m1
machines which is a workload optimized
family
at the end of the day the right vm will
largely be based on what you're going to
use that virtual machine for and then
from there figuring out how much cpu and
memory you'll need
this can help distinguish the machine
needed
for example amd machines come in larger
configuration sizes
or if you require high memory volume
memory optimize is the way to go
if you're migrating an application from
an on-prem system we recommend some
benchmarking and data collection to
understand the application
characteristics or testing the
application on the machine type before
deploying it in production when choosing
your cpu and memory requirements you
should also be sure to pay attention to
the flip side the cpu and memory that
you don't need
that is you should be careful not to
over provision your machine for example
a general purpose n2 standard 2 will
provide you with two virtual cpus and 8
gigabytes of memory
but let's say the application you're
going to run on the instance uses most
of the cpu most of the time
but never really uses more than about 2
gigabytes of memory
well in that case you might be better
off on an n2 high cpu2 instance that way
you're not getting billed for six extra
gigabytes of memory that you don't need
making sure you're provisioning just the
right machine for your needs ensures
that you're not overpaying for resources
that you may never use if you're not
sure no worries
google cloud provides right sizing
recommendations based on your usage data
to get the sizing just right these
recommendations are available within the
compute engine instance page or within
the recommendations hub if none of the
available machine types fit your
requirements keep in mind there's always
custom machine types with custom machine
types you can configure just the right
amount of cpu and memory for your
particular needs
in some cases you could expect to save
50 or more compared to predefined types
on other public cloud providers with all
things considered if you're still not
sure what machine type to choose start
off with something small you can always
move your workload to a larger machine
at any time besides cpu and memory
another performance metric you should
consider is disk performance if your
application needs the best disk iops
you're going to want to make sure that
you choose an instance type that will be
compatible with one of two high
performance disk solutions
local ssds and extreme persistent disks
local ssds have the advantage of being
physically attached to the server that
hosts your vm so you can get higher
throughput and lower latency than
standard persistent disks
they offer local block storage that is
ephemeral and great for processing space
buffers caches and other temporary data
and for high-end performance critical
applications extreme persistent disks
will offer higher maximum iops and
throughput than other options but keep
in mind it'll require at least 64
virtual cpus
beyond disks there are other features
that you may need to check compatibility
for when choosing your vm there's
confidential computing this is a service
that encrypts data in use while it's
being processed
the transition to confidential vms is
seamless all workloads we run today can
also run as confidential vms
no extra code changes to applications
just one checkbox to protect against
rootkit and boot kits
but if you plan on using confidential
computing you'll have to choose an n2d
from the general purpose family of vms
or a c2d from the compute optimize
family
another feature is sole tenancy this
lets you have exclusive access to a
physical compute engine server that's
dedicated to only the vms in your
project this can be required for
licensing of certain applications with
any compute engine feature be sure to
check out the documentation for vm
compatibility when you're deciding on
what vm to choose so now that we know
how to choose a vm let's choose a vm
let's say that my only requirement as of
right now is a virtual machine with 16
virtual cpus
with only that requirement let's see
what options i have the workload
optimized machines could be a good
starting point
c2 standard 16 will give me the cpu that
i want
it's a standard type so it's got
standard cpu memory ratio what about
general purpose machines what do they
have to offer we'll start with seeing if
e2s will be a fit
well an e2 standard 16 has similar
specifications
16 virtual cpus and 64 gigs of memory
and it's priced a bit lower than the
workload optimized c2 we'll add that as
a possible choice noting that this would
save us some cost over time
okay now what if the performance of our
application will need some block storage
local ssds are an excellent solution
here
according to the documentation we can
attach a local ssd to an e2 nor a t2d
machine but we can attach one to a c2
we still want a general purpose option
that's not a problem there's n2 standard
16 and 2d standard 16 and the n1
standard 16. all of these general
purpose machines offer the same
specifications on different micro
architectures and are compatible with
local ssd
all right
now what if we did some testing and
found out that while we can't budge on
cpu our application actually runs pretty
well with less memory
this is our chance to optimize our cost
by choosing a high cpu machine type n2
high cpu 16 n2d hype cpu 16 and n1 high
cpu 16
all have the same cpu as the other
options but with only 16 gigabytes of
memory
c2 machines are highly performant so our
application will run great on one
but we'll be spending more on additional
performance and memory that won't be
used so let's just remove c2 from our
list
based on our requirements so far we've
narrowed down our choice to any of these
three choices
as more machine families in series are
added to the compute engine lineup your
available options might differ it's
always a good idea to check the latest
documentation when researching what vm
will work for you
so what do you think
what factors came into play when you
chose to write vm
let us know in the comments
until next time
[Music]